let's talk about this from the BBC
White House says there are no visitor
logs for Biden's home okay so not only
did he have classified documents stored
there more than we originally thought
Hunter Biden lived there was funneling
money to his dad and we don't know who
showed up if Hunter was living there if
he actually was you know why there's no
visitor log because the list of hookers
would be too long they'd just be like we
got we got her it's all right we got
destiny Laquisha Pink Panther Lotus is a
good stripper name Ian do you know
something candy don't need
Andy Agnes yeah she's older and how many
of them are like Fang Fang like Russia
you know not Russian or Chinese spies I
guarantee you some of them are probably
spies Joe walks in and Hunter's got like
two Russian women on his arms and he's
sunglasses and he's smoking a joint and
he's like who are these should I see
Scarlet yeah I don't know spies I guess
how did they get past security what
security there's no logs there's no
security they're sitting there like
reading the classified documents I hope
champagne you could read
as much as what are you doing synonym
right I want Hunter keep it in my man no
matter cardamom and rosemary how angry
you are Joe like I get Hunter you're
probably pissed off a joke is the way he
treated you throughout your life but you
never would have had a chance to live
like this without him like you would
have had some cheap job that you hated
barely stringing by you wouldn't have
enough money to pull you out of the
gutter when you fell so like be be
thankful to your dad no way dude I think
I think Joe diddled Hunter
for sure yeah I wouldn't be surprised
what don't say thank him yeah yeah but
don't just put it all on Joe Hunter
you've been sucking off the tit your
whole life man it's your responsibility
taking care of yourself I think Hunter's
a bad dude but I think he got abused by
Joe Biden like you see the Ashley Biden
stuff oh yeah you watch Joe Biden grow
children and sniff them what do you
think he was doing Hunter Biden back at
home true after he lost his daughter and
his wife like what happened to him
that would be surprised if he took it
all out on Hunter and it's true is it
true that he and Jill Jill had an affair
and her husband with Joe that that's a
rumor I can't confirm that but Beau was
always rest in peace to Beau Bai and he
was always the star he was the one that
was supposed to be president now not Joe
and then the problem was Bo Biden was
the good one he was The Good Son Hunter
was always the Dark Horse the you know
the black sheep so that that will mess
with you mentally too on top of I don't
know what other stuff was going on what
happened to the good one
what's the cancer from um well I forgot
how he I think I think they attribute it
to uh his time in Iraq yeah I think Joe
did I wasn't I'm not sure if that is
exactly why but Joe did he thinks that
could have played but then Joe claimed
that he died in Iraq no no yep yep he
did yeah yeah he's just he's just gone
no he's not I mean Joe lies about
everything remember when he in the 80s
he plagiarized that entire Irish dude's
life yeah oh yeah every once he was
saying he was like the top of his class
or something like that like he left
school I went to the coal mines yeah he
said so much the family worked Beau
Biden died in 2015 uh from brain cancer
at the age of 46. and they thought it
was from like extensive exposure to burn
pits and stuff like that yeah is that
what it was uh it doesn't say doesn't
hear we don't know for sure on that one
yeah there's a book that came out saying
it could have been that nobody knows for
sure but Beau Biden was a star
politician I mean he was next in line
um he was very good military vet yeah
yeah
wow
yeah and now that all I got is Hunter
yeah that's got to be Hunter 2020. it's
so sad I mean if there's ever going to
be a Redemption Arc it has to be with
Hunter right I would vote for if Hunter
was running for president of the United
States I would vote for him immediately
experience who do you want to run in the
country someone who has never lived a
life of of of of of of of excitement of
of just experience or or someone who's
been sheltered in this innocent entire
life I would watch a hunter Biden
YouTube channel and enjoy it oh that
would be dull but I would not vote for a
Biden any of them yeah no I I think he
would he would be able to deal with
serious problems that Americans are
dealing with because he dealt with them
himself yeah if he got the job he'd keep
funneling money to his dad that'd be the
whole bit yeah well that's what they're
doing already like I know that wouldn't
change anything but look I'm
disappointed in you what about fetterman
I know
make it all burn down as quickly as
possible make make the shirt better than
Biden 2020 Hunter Biden John fetterman
2024 just make it all burn down faster
why I look at Hunter Biden's Wikipedia
page and the picture they used for make
him look like Steve Carell in his
awkward office moments like Michael
Michael Scott super awkward big eyes and
then maybe that's just how he looks
Hunter it's all blurry the picture's
blurry like they couldn't just get a
normal picture of him looking you know
charismatic I asked the audience does
this prove Hunter laundered money to Joe
89 say yes
so the challenge with evidence and proof
right proof would be like catching him
whole holding like handing the money I
actually think this is as closest to
proof as you're going to get like him
stating definitively on on a background
check application that he did give this
money to his dad I suppose what would be
better is a bank log showing the
transfer so we know what actually
happened yeah but him stating he did it
is as close to a confession as you're
gonna get yeah I would say it's evidence
not proof I said no on that poll because
it could be Dr uh paper it could be
doctor there's no official stamp on it
um and it could be a lie about the
amount fair point but any evidence could
be doctored any and all of it could be
doctored like you go to you're in trial
because the guy got murdered like here's
the murder weapon it's like maybe
they've fabricated so I would look for
preponderance of evidence to decide
proof if there's enough evidence that I
could say that's probably not doctored
or how about how about this
Hunter Biden said he was paying the
family expenses Hunter Biden says his
dad was was taking half his salary in
the emails he said 10 for the big guy
and then he's giving 10 times the
high-end rent for a rental property that
Joe Biden owns this record should be
looked into this is crazy yeah we're
really close to proof and what I do on
my channel a lot is bring to the bigger
picture you're talking about there are
no logs at his private residence so that
means he can I think he spent 200 days
there he could bring anybody over there
and talk about whatever they're talking
about uh looking at the big picture
don't we have enough to just really as a
country all agree we need to look into
it like is why would we have a bypro you
know a partisan type of battle over this
wouldn't you think anybody on any
political Spectrum would say this
doesn't look right well part of what
I've been thinking as is the great age
of Pardons that we're upon is like okay
the liberal economic order is turning
into the New World Order we need to make
oversee this change and why why do we
hate ourselves for being the pilots of
the Death Star for the last 70 years
like we were basically trying to
militaristically control Earth as the
United States like people did horrible
horrible things Henry Kissinger Joe
Biden you name it Donald Trump all these
people with all these secrets and it's
like dude we gotta like make the New
World Order now we need to make a
republican style decentralized statehood
across earth or of the Chinese and the
world economic Forum are going to do it
for us and they're going to make a
corporate communist state
so I want to forgive people that's where
I'm at right now I don't even want to go
after Trump and Biden for the stupid
stuff like we have a bigger deal I I
just want to say there's like a very big
difference between Trump Biden and Klaus
Schwab and all these people like when
these people were murdering children
Trump was firing people on TV like the
worst thing Trump was doing was selling
Pepsi or whatever or being in Home Alone
movies I guess building hotels the
argument is like the worst of the worst
American Military psychos that have been
controlling this liberal economic order
I'm just I don't feel like witch hunting
because we're going to end up pulling
back the curtain realizing we've all
been involved in it we've all been
benefiting from it like it's true that
we have we've been greatly benefiting
from uh from the US Empire the
petrodollar and all that stuff and uh
I'm not a fan of this idea that the US
is the World Police I kind of like the
idea that we mind our own business but
since what 1913 that's not been the case
and where the deaths are you know
yeah do we do we do we shut it all down
what are we doing Death Star the New
Order
the New World Order you fear is already
here and they're working with the
Chinese and these internationalists
don't give a damn about the United
States they use that as a vehicle they
use that as a vessel just like they use
China just like they're testing all the
latest Big Brother surveillance
technology there they're going with
their plan of what works out best for
them they have no allegiance to the
United States they're not American
they're internationalists so you got to
understand from that perspective and
when they talk about a new world order
they're talking about continuing pretty
much the way that the things are but for
a better benefit for them
well we would need like a populist an
upright New World Order like a popular
world order that people actually want
not let corporations top down decided
yeah that's Mega that's how I view Maga
what you just said I wouldn't say the
New World Order just because it rubs
people the wrong way but yeah it's a
populist movement you saw the hold up of
the speaker vote we we haven't seen
anything like that in 100 years
international national nationalism
that's what people were jokingly
referring to it as like the idea that
there was a movement of individuals to
strengthen their own countries and their
own borders and respect between
different countries to allow each to do
so
so the media tried mocking the idea but
it was actually quite simple it meant
that someone from the UK was like hey
this is where I live we want to have
these rules that's totally cool that you
live over there and want to have those
rules and then we'll figure out how to
work together and everyone's like yeah
that sounds like a really great idea so
it's an international movement to
restore and strengthen National
boundaries yeah I think Libertarians
have the answer you hear comic Dave
Smith on this show and how based he is
decentralization like you just mentioned
yeah that's the answer to me
yeah they have the United States of
Mexico is already primed we've got the
United States of America we've got
Canada's basically a bunch of provinces
States uh China's a bunch of States like
we're we're really as long as the People
Want it we're prepped to create a
decentralized state across the planet
maybe he's just gonna you know in order
to get these other countries to
recognize the superior way in which our
government works we need to bomb the
crap out of them maybe maybe the hardest
thing we need to do and take their oil
is just you know go there
and then just make them implement this
and then after we make them do it
they'll understand why it's so good we
travel they may resist but
we have bigger guns than they do well I
think really the key that worked really
well in Afghanistan that's right the key
would be to teach them English and get
people to use English as a primary
language if we all have one language I
think that the best ideas win yeah no no
that's a good idea that's a good idea
but but the other issue is that they
might still try to speak their own
language and adhere to their own
cultural tradition so you beat them no
but this is why Hollywood was so great
for the American culture in the last
hundred years is because it spread
English across the planet and English
became the language of business and you
know you know when you understand what
American freedom-loving people are
saying it's a lot easier to get on board
the solution to a lot of the world's
problems is individuals not trying to
force their will onto others and as long
as people realize that and respect other
people and respect their property and
their individual sovereignty then and
only then the world will be a better
place but when we have the Karens when
we have Kyle saying you need to do this
you need to follow this religion or this
edict or this woke Doctrine and you have
to do it or I will get and use extortion
and force with centralized police forces
in order to push my ideology onto you
that right there is the larger problem
of our society and why it is where it is
right now and it takes personal
responsibility individuals being strong
and independent and saying hey I respect
you as an individual respect me uh
standing up for themselves being strong
being able to defend themselves that
truly will lead us out of this but
without you mayor the globalist New
World Order nightmare that we all are a
part of with that mindset if someone
were to instantiate like a revolution to
statehood like Republican statehood or
something would you I mean the
libertarian mindset's kind of like let
them do it I'm not involved but like
usually you can't revolt against your
system without outside help so like at
what point would you suggest no other
countries always get involved and of
course just like the United States got
involved in Ukraine It's a larger proxy
war but again conflict is usually
routine with that kind of larger idea
this is why I'm saying what you're
describing is one of the problems I'm
describing people trying to force
something on someone else once we get
rid of that Force once we get to that
rid of that extortion just that that
belief system of respecting others there
wouldn't be those kind of confrontations
there wouldn't be those types of
situations what I'm talking about is
kind of utopian but more of just like a
a place where I think we should be going
to as Humanity where we could progress
to a point where we could respect each
other's differences without trying to
bomb or kill each other the current
ethos are the current uh
philosophy I suppose is whoever holds
the biggest stick
because if you don't hold it someone
else will and so the United States is
basically like look our system is better
we got all of these civil rights we've
expanded throughout the years we've done
a great job of things let's just hold
the biggest stick and beat anybody who
disagrees that way we don't got to worry
about them beating a big stick against
us and that's why the you know all the
Cold War was so crucial for these people
that's why the draft Vietnam and all
these countries that's why they used
false flags all that mattered was we
were bigger and more powerful so we
don't got to worry about it they
genuinely believe that by being the
being the Death Star being the Empire
you prevent war and suffering so it's
almost like their attitude is there's
got to be some there's got to be some
suffering some War and then you know
we'll make sure there's not too much of
it
that was The Limited War uh Doctrine
messenger's Doctrine so we would you
know if instead of bombing Moscow if
Russia was going to war in Northern
Vietnam we just fight proxy war in
Vietnam basically what's going on
Ukraine you don't just bomb Moscow
because you're angry that they invaded
Ukraine then Moscow doesn't bomb
Washington DC or Syria total or Libya or
Vietnam yeah it was a mess the the
liberal War Machine went so haywire when
they invaded Iraq and Afghanistan I
think that was when you realized the
first time the second time the second
time was when it was like you have gone
too far you lose the big stick you you
failed whoever's in control of this
system has failed you but I think that
was the first time so they had to try
again they had failed
the well I mean just ethically as a
geopolitical police uh invading the
Middle East like that is an epic failure
like that was I don't know if they
didn't realize that technology was just
so great you can fly bomber planes
around Earth there's no you know yeah
have you seen have you guys seen The
Solar planes that can fly forever yeah
yeah now imagine they put bombs in those
things and they just have them fly
around forever and then it's just like
don't step on it don't you know they
probably already have that yep or the
the the scary thought was the uh you
ever hear of rods from God you know
about this one oh yeah it's uh
satellites carrying giant tungsten rods
they just drop it and slams into the
Earth
I guess the argument is it's too it's
too uh takes too much energy to put the
rod in space in the first place and then
maintain its orbit but being able to
drop
so it just stays up there until they're
ready to drop it yeah they don't release
it if you watch the GI Joe movie that's
what they do oh no I didn't see that
yeah Cobra Commander oh yeah and he
presses the button then he blows up
London
just with a single tungsten Rod yeah it
slams in the whole London just ripples
into the air thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time